everybody um thank you for joining us
this lunch time
uh for what is a very timely and
important webinar discussion
with our good friend michelle barnier
the eu chief negotiator
and head of the european commission's
task force for relations with
the united kingdom uh my name is michael
collins and i'm the director general of
the
institute of international and european
affairs the iea
here in dublin and we are absolutely
delighted to be co-hosting this event
with the european commission
representation here
in ireland brexit hasn't gone away of
course and
time is ticking away as we approach the
december deadline we've had a huge uh
amount of interest in today's event
with well over 1 500 people signing up
from ireland from the uk from across
europe and indeed from beyond that as
well and this is a testament
to how important the ongoing
negotiations are
as we enter the final crucial phase
that lies ahead uh before handing over
to michelle barnier i will just run
through some of the format
details of this event the full event
today is on
the record the initial presentation and
the questions
and answer sessions that will follow you
can join the discussion
using zoom's dedicated queue and a
function
and i would encourage you to submit your
questions as they occur to you
throughout the presentation given the
huge volume of questions that we expect
please keep your questions as brief as
possible
in the interest of getting through as
many as we can please identify yourself
and submitting your question
your name and your affiliation if that
is applicable
lastly we also encourage you to join the
discussion on social media
namely through twitter uh please join in
using the handle
at i i e a
so with that mr barnier uh you're very
very welcome indeed
thank you for being on this important uh
with us on this important day
and on this iiea platform i now like to
hand over to you
the floor is yours
many thanks sir michael ladies and
gentlemen good afternoon
uh the aiv thank you also for
tuning in i hope you are
all safe and well despite the difficult
very difficult circumstances
let me start by thanking the institute
for international and european affairs
michael
for inviting me and your team and for
your kind words
for many years already your institute
has played a key role
in helping the public to better
understand the implication of brexit for
ireland
and also your thoughtful analysis and
recommendations
have also been useful for us in brussels
here in brussels
and in national capitals i would like
also to thank the european commission's
representation in ireland and its head
gerry kiley
for helping to organize this event as
well as for
all the support you have given to our
task force
over the last years i'm very happy to
for this new opportunity to interact
with all of you today even
if only virtually
the coronary aris pandemic continues to
take lives
around the world and dealing with the
sanitary crisis
and its very serious economic and social
consequences
naturally remains the very first
priority of governments
and businesses this is also of course
one of the main priorities of the
european commission
and its presidents jose la van der laan
and there are obviously other major
projects and ambitions for the future of
europe
which president van der lion will
present in a
very important speech on the state of
the union
on the 16th of september
but as you all know ladies and gentlemen
the pandemic does not stop
the brexit clock from ticking
we are now less than four four months
away from the first of january uh to
2021. this is a day chosen by the uk
itself itself for its economic and
commercial brexit after the political
brexit in january
this year because as you know the uk
refused
any extension of the transition period
so we have no more time to lose
we must have a final agreement by the
end of october
if we are to have a new partnership in
place by the first
january 2021
and as i have already explained this is
the only way to give
enough time to the european parliament
and
the council to have their say
this is a legal and democratic necessity
everyone everyone everywhere
must be realistic about this strict
deadline ladies and gentlemen
the economic brexit will in any case
have
negative consequences many negative
consequences
but if we all act responsibly
we can contain some of those
consequences
back in february i mentioned
three major tasks for this year
number one negotiating our
future partnership number two
implementing the withdrawal agreement
ratified
last year number three getting ready
for changes at the end of the transition
the first of january these three
tasks are closely interlinked
and completing each of them is urgent
i know this sense of urgency is strong
in ireland
and northern ireland without a doubt
ireland is a member state most affected
by bext and of course for the island of
ireland
brexit negotiations have not just been
about trade
and the economy but more existentially
about maintaining peace and stability
that is why since the very beginning of
the brexit negotiation
four years ago i've been very attentive
to the concerns voiced by the all the
different parties and communities
in ireland and northern ireland
i've worked closely very closely
with ireland's successive
teaching and dakini liu varadkar
and today mirol martin and with
minister simon coveney and other members
of government
i've exchanged views with the dole
and shen ad as well as all the irish
members
of the european parliament together
we carried forward the close
relationship between
ireland and the rest of the eu based on
solidarity
solidarity and respect
ladies and gentlemen in this context i
will miss philogen
on whom i could always count to relay
any irish concerns to me
very directly over the last four years
i would like to take this opportunity to
thank him
warmly for all the work he has done for
europe
as commissioner for agriculture and
rural development
and more recently as commissioner for
trade
in particular in the context of the
current negotiations
with the uk where he and
his team of trade experts including
obviously sabine vayant has been a great
value i used to meet him once a week
as trade commissioner once a week and i
look forward to working with the future
commissioner for of irish nationality
in the final stretch of the negotiation
with the uk
ladies and gentlemen uh before opening
up the discussion between us
let me tell you where we stand on the
three
important tasks that are mentioned
first of all let's turn to our current
negotiations with the uk on the future
partnership
we want a close partnership with the uk
provided the conditions are right
this is in everybody's interest
everybody
had in ireland's interest in particular
so far
the uk frankly speaking has not engaged
constructively
in all those conditions and as i have
said before
i am particularly worried and
disappointed
at the uk's lack of engagement on three
points
first point since the start of this
negotiations
the uk has refused to engage on credible
guarantees for open and fair
competition open and fair
yes the eu has been clear about this
from the very very beginning
four years ago any trade and economy
partnership
between economies as clothes are
interacted are ours look at
my one of my favorite slide
showing on the two axes
on one end the distance
and on the other and the volume
of exchanges with
our main partners in the world
this show this shows clearly
why we need this economic and commercial
fair play and credible mechanisms to
avoid
trade distortions and unfair competitive
advantages this is particularly
important in the area of stated
where the potential to distort
competition using subsidies
is clearly significant
a level playing field that ensures
common high
standards in areas such as labor
rights and the environment and with
effective domestic enforcement and
dispute settlement mechanism
is the only way the only way to start a
new relationship between the eu and the
uk
on a firm and sustainable footing
and it is also what the prime minister
johnson
himself agreed on to explicitly in
uh this text which is the political
declaration ratified
and agreed between us the prime minister
and the 27 leaders and european
parliament
at the end of last year
second point second point
since the start of these negotiations
the uk has not shown any willingness
to seek compromises on fisheries
contrary to media reports even this week
the uk government's position has not
evolved in past
months no legal new no
legal no new legal texts
have been tabled by uk negotiators
where the eu has shown openness to
possible solutions
the uk has shunned our offers
yet the uk government's positions would
lock on
islands fishermen and women from waters
they fished in long before ireland
or the uk joint the european economic
community
in 73 and of course
the fishermen and women of many other eu
countries
that is just not acceptable
ladies and gentlemen we fully understand
and respect
that the uk will become an independent
coastal state
outside the common fisheries policy
outside of this european policy
but we will not accept that the work and
the livelihoods
of this man and woman be used as a
bargaining chip
in these negotiations a new solution
must ensure balance between further
developing the activities of british
fishermen
and women safeguarding the activities
and livelihood
of european fishermen and women and
preserving
natural resources
without a long term without a long-term
fair and sustainable solution on
fisheries
there will simply be no new economic
partnership
with the uk finally
third point since the start
of these negotiations the uk has been
extremely reluctant to include
any meaningful horizontal dispute
settlement
mechanisms in our future agreement
yet this is the only way to ensure
that what we eventually agree on
is respected on all these
issues we are simply asking
to translate the political engagement
taken in this
text in the political declaration in a
legal text
just a legal transition of the political
commitments taken
by the uk government and by bad eu
leaders
nothing more nothing less
nothing more nothing less yet
on all these issues the uk sides
continue to disappoint
we know well the uk's argument he wants
a clean
break from the eu you want
full sovereignty and the freedom to set
its own rules and spend its own money
as it wants with no constraints
from europe and for all these reasons
the uk insists it cannot commit to a
level playing field
or to basic safeguards for our future
relationship not even
when it comes to fundamental rights and
yet
the truth is that british negotiators
are still seeking continuity in many
areas
not a clean break at all for instance on
transport
or on energy trading on its role for
conformity assessments for goods
and on many
aspects of police and judicial
cooperation the uk government
is still looking to keep the benefits of
the eu
and of the single market without the
obligations
the uk often says he would be in the u's
interest to grant
it a special statue in these strategic
areas of cooperation
but frankly speaking is it really
the eu's long-term economic interest
for instance british proposals
and rules of origin would help the uk to
develop
its role as an assembly hub
for the eu they would allow the uk to
source
goods from around the world and export
them
with very little alteration to the eu
as british goods tariff and cote were
free
british proposals on road transport
another example
would allow british truckers to drive on
e-roads without having the to comply
with the same
working conditions at eu drivers
the uk's proposal on air transport third
example
would allow british airlines to operate
inside the eu
without having to respect the same labor
and environmental standards
in the area of energy the uk is asking
to facilitate electricity trade
without committing its producers to
equivalent carbon pricing
and state aid controls
in this area as in others
without a common framework on stated
the uk government would be free to hand
out subsidies at will
not just to support the green economy
but also polluting industries
not just to support industry of the
future but also traditional sectors
such as steel and automotive
before exporting these tariffs and
contra free
to our market ladies and gentlemen
we have no wish to intervene no wish
to intervene in the uk's domestic
affairs
but how can we conclude a long-term
economic partnership agreement between
sovereign partners
sovereign partners on both sides without
knowing
which system of state aid or subsidies
the uk will put in place without
any assurances that the uk
will not use its new regulatory autonomy
to distort competition with us in the
future
i note with interest
a recent speech by the chief executive
of the environment agency for england
sir james bevin he
suggested that after brexit
water quality standards for english
rivers
lakes and beaches should be less
rigorous than under the used water
framework directive
of course this raises major
environmental and health
concerns but let us consider the
economic too
if english farmers and industrials are
no longer bound
by our standards on water pollution
would they gain decisive and unfair
cost advantages we have
no issue with regulatory
divergence
it is normal that the uk wants to set
its
own standards and rules normal and it is
the reason of the brexit
but this serves to distort competition
with us then we have a problem
and there are other areas where the uk
insists
on being able to diverge substantially
from its current standards as of the 1st
of january
next year i'm thinking for ins for
example for instance
of the food sector here
not only is the uk looking to go back
to go back and protections for
geographical indications
secured the wizard agreement
he has also given us no reassurance
on the future sanitary and fight or
sanitary regime
that the uk will apply after the first
january next year
how can we make progress on sanitary
and phyto-sanitary shoes when we have no
id no id how the uk system will
evolve ladies and gentlemen
these are not technocratic details
these are essentials at stake
are tens of thousands of european jobs
and livelihoods irish jobs and
livelihoods
our health safety and well-being
our environment and climate our
fundamental rights
of course ireland's particularly close
relationship with the uk
makes these questions even more
important
especially for businesses exporting to
great britain
or competing with british companies
ladies and gentlemen thankfully
the withdrawal agreement means that we
have a stable
solution for goods trade between ireland
and northern ireland without a hard
border on the island
it is essential to protect the whole
island economy
this is precisely why our second
important task
before the end of this year before the
end of this year
is to ensure the full and effective
implementation
the withdrawal agreement in particular
as regards
citizens rights and obviously the
protocol on ireland
and northern ireland and this remains
an absolutely priority for the eu
it is the only way to protect the good
friday the good and belfast friday
agreement
and all its dimensions and therefore to
protect the gains of the peace process
which people like devin tremble truneum
simus mallon martin magnus and
jan pesley worked so hard
for with the support of course of
successive irish and british governments
and of the eu obviously
a precise implementation of the
withdrawal agreement is also the only
way
to avoid the art border on the island of
ireland and preserve the old island
economy it is the only way
to preserve the integrity of the single
market and
all its guarantees for consumer
protection
public and animal health by ensuring
all the necessary checks and controls
for goods
entering northern ireland and of course
it is a preconditions for us
the eu and the uk to be able to forge
a meaningful partnership built on trust
for the future
in recent months under the impetus of
michael gove
the uk has started to make progress on
the implementation of the protocol
and this is encouraging but important
questions remain
open the eu needs to be sure that the
union customs code will be applied
in its entirety for goods
arriving in northern ireland similarly
we need to know that goods leaving
northern ireland respect
all applicable eu export procedures
and formalities and finally we need to
be certain
that all necessary controls are carried
out on live animals and animal derived
products
arriving in northern ireland from great
britain and the rest of the world
to ensure that this agreement works
on the ground on the ground as of the
1st january next year
the uk still needs to complete many
many practical preparations time
consuming
and resource intensive preparations and
of course
and of course we will also continue
to be extremely vigilant when it comes
to ensuring
the full respect of citizens rights
under
this wheelchair agreement both in the uk
and in the 27 eu member states
together with by the president
marosevkovic
we continue to follow closely the uk's
actions
ladies and gentlemen the rigorous
implementation to the protocol
this protocol will serve to protect
peace
and stability on the island of ireland
once again
and of course an ambitious future
partnership with the uk
would help limit the negative impact
of brexit for ireland for the eu and for
the uk
but even with this two pillar in place
and we are not yet there there will be
big
changes on the 1st january 2021
on that date the uk will leave the
single market
we leave the customs union and all eu
policies
and all our international agreements
this is his choice not our choice
let me mention just a few examples of
what this means
concretely on that day the 1st of
january
custom formalities will apply to all our
imports and exports with the uk
on that date the eu
will no longer recognize
uk types approvals for cars for instance
on that date financial institutions
established in the uk
will lose the benefit of the eu's
financial passport this is the uk
consequence the brexit consequences
clearly
no trade agreement no matter how
ambitious
can change this businesses
public administrations and citizens
must urgently get ready for these
changes
here again ireland's unique geographical
situation means that
it will particularly affected
many irish importers and exporters
rely on the uk as a key route to and
and from the rest of the eu their land
bridge to
and from the du we have been working
with ireland and relevant member states
to ensure
that this key connection to the single
market remains
effective the uk party
the uk's participation in the common
transit convention will certainly
help this regard and on the eu side
our major entry and exit points are
ready
but there are still concerns
as to the readiness of some key uk ports
and irish businesses transport operators
ports and shipping companies will have
to play their part in adapting
to the new situation many
already have shipping companies have
increased
capacity on direct services on the
continent
businesses are reorganizing their
distribution chains
and diversifying their market
more generally
more generally ireland has
done very good preparative work
i particularly commend the government's
getting ireland brexit ready
campaign and i know this work is
continuing
i trust in your capacity to adapt
to new times very new times
finally to help stakeholders across the
eu to prepare
to commission adopted readiness
communication
last july times of july
we have also published more than 80
80 sectoral notices
with more detailed guidance which are
being translated
in all eu languages and
we are working with all 27 national
administrations
to make sure that these changes huge
changes
are communicated clearly and understood
by
all ladies and gentlemen
dear michael as we
near the fin finish the finish line i
still have hope
that despite current tensions our
communist
history with the uk shared value
and joint commitment towards militarism
will
prevail
who passed away seven years ago this
week
like to quote the words of another
great european vassal
and he said
and he wrote hope
is not optimism which expects
things to turn out well but
something rooted in the conviction
there is good worth working for
ladies and gentlemen i continue to think
despite the current difficulties that
prime minister boyce johnson
wants an agreement with the eu
he confirmed this recently to our
european shock miral martin
this is also the wish of presidents
ursula van der leyen and charles michel
the wish of the european parliament the
wish of the 27
heads of state and government
and we will do everything in our power
to reach an agreement until the very
very end but
to be clear will not sacrifice
never sacrifice the eu's long-term
economic and political interests for the
sole
benefit of the uk
in past months the eu
has repeatedly shown flexibility and
creativity
to work with the uk's red lines and the
role of the european court of justice
for instance
on preserving the uk's legislative
autonomy
on on fisheries it's time
for the uk to reciprocate on those
issues
that are fundamental for the eu
i will be back in london next week for
our
eighth negotiating round as planned
and i sincerely hope to be able to tell
you
a new story after that round
a story of real tangible progress
in all areas
and thank you for your attention i'm now
ready
to answer some questions of course
michael i ask for your understanding
should i not enter into into details
given that negotiations are now ongoing
thank you thank you michelle that that's
of course
fully understood and thank you for your
uh your words in gaelic as well in irish
very much appreciated and your poetic uh
references as well to the late uh great
uh
sheamus heaney uh so and thank you
indeed uh michelle for
getting us back up to speed uh because
we've had a summer break
and i think it's really really important
that we should now be reminded
of the huge amount of work that still
needs to be
undertaken by you and your team and by
the uk as well
but as you say the clock is ticking
uh ever more loudly as december
approaches
uh so we really do appreciate the ups
the the update that you've given us
and the insight into the current state
of play
so i'm going to turn to a few questions
in the time available to us uh
michelle and um there are several
questions in about your mandate and i'm
just going to take one if i may
from our good friend the the belgian
ambassador here
uh pierre emanuel de bro here in dublin
and he wants to know he says do you
foresee
a need for adapting your mandate
in order to find a landing zone with
the uk and i suppose the question is do
you have
enough flexibility in your mandate
to you allow to allow you to
complete the negotiations successfully
biker if the the question of the belgium
ambassador
in dublin is to us ask me if i have
enough flexibility my answer is yes
this flexibility is clearly linked to
the trust
we built between the u-27 leaders the
european parliament and
my team working under the authority of
the yusuf and area and the commission
with all the
the trust and the confidence of this uh
this house where i am in brussels the
commission all the services
the directions many many experts
um very important competences
my answer is yes i think that this
mandate is clear
he has been given in the unity and
total clarity by the eu member states
and supported by the european parliament
and
i i think i can use this mandate
and this trust
towards my team and perhaps myself
to to to find a compromise but
this mandate is also linked to the new
interests
and as i said in my initial remarks
we are ready and we want a deal but not
at any price
and we will never pay the price
if uh it would be at the detriment of
the single market the integrity of
single market and
the value that eu and interest in the
long term of the
eu never so um
michelle just a question here from
german o'leary just to follow up on that
i mean clearly
uh from within the membership of the
european council
there remains a unanimous support for
what you're doing and the approach that
you're taking
yes but once again my answer is yes
there is a unanimous support of the 27
leaders and i checked this point
on a regular basis meeting for instance
the ambassador the co-repair
speaking with the leaders personally
speaking with uh
the sherpa uh as the president of the
commission at the present european
council sean mitchell
obviously are doing every day
i work in to deliver this mandate
so uh there is no no no way to to any
kind of
divergence or difference between what i
am doing and
and the wish and the will of the the
leaders but let me
just mention one point the disunity
of the 27 member states and the
parliament
is is not given by chance
it's not falling from the sky we are
working
and we are building this unity
every day uh meeting the leaders meeting
the national parliament between the
stakeholders
the business communities the the trade
unions
obviously meeting the european
parliament every week
this unity is built every day thanks or
through
perhaps an unusual method we have put in
place with the
support of the presidential commission
which is
a total transparency
perhaps one point that reaches some
difficulty to understand
from the very beginning but this is the
case
we say everything every day to everybody
and in that process every member states
every member when all the
each of the 27 member states are the the
same influence
and the same information at the same
time okay
okay just uh two questions are questions
here from uh two journalists uh who i
know
write regularly on brexit issues from
the guardian jennifer rankin
and lisa o'carroll and referencing
your visit to london yesterday they
asked um
after your meeting with david frost
yesterday
has there been any change in the uk's
position
on estate aid level playing fields or
fisheries
that could open the way a for a deal
and i know you don't want to get into
the detail of negotiations and that's
understood the second question that they
have is
is it true that the united the eu is
refusing
to discuss the uk's proposal on
fishing and finally a simple question
out of 10
what are the chances of no deal
once again i don't want to enter the
details of my
discussion with david frost who is a
very strong
and competent negotiator for the uk and
the team also
has my team is very competent
but this this week
yesterday and i came back from london
this morning
uh we didn't see any change in the
position of the uk
this is why i expressed publicly what i
said i am
worried and i am disappointed because
frankly speaking we have we have moved
i've i've shown in many issue
real openness in the last few months
trying to reach the british concern the
british priority what we call the
pretty straight line expressed by the
prime minister on the role of the court
of justice
the british sovereignty what i call the
legislative autonomy of the
uk we want to respect obviously and also
the the the fishing issue and i have
i've shown clearly openness to find a
compromise
respecting my mandate and using this
flexibility and this trust
and on none of this issue
the uk moved in a kind of reciprocal
movement so
the reason why i'm concerned because if
they don't move
on this issue which are the key issue of
the eu
level playing field fishery and
governance
uh the uk will take
will take itself the risk
of the new deal i already mentioned the
point of this
press comments this week on fishery
this article
was and is ridiculous because it is
clearly
contrary to the truth
so i don't think that the the source
if i may say of this journalist writing
for the times
was the correct ones
no other comments at this point and last
point
michael i don't think we can you can use
the word the word chance for the
for an odin yeah if i may i will use
the word of risk of an ordeal not a
chance as you mentioned
we are working for a deal let me just
mention one point
make no mistake make no mistake
there will be a huge difference
between a deal and a no deal on trade
and economy
between the uk and the uk and the eu a
huge difference
sometimes i listen some in uk
speaking of the chance of a no deal the
opportunity of a no deal
good luck good luck but
frankly speaking there is no reason
to underestimate who undermining
the the consequences for many people
many sectors
of a no deal there will be a huge
difference
between a deal and an audience the the
reason why we are working for deal and
for the moment i still hope and i still
think
even it is very difficult because of the
british positions that a deal is
possible
okay okay just um you very
generously and warmly referred to the
contribution that
commissioner former commissioner phil
hogan uh played and made
on in relation to his portfolios as
commission
commissioner uh it's a question here and
we just take this one
from justin mccarthy who's the editor of
the irish farmers
journal and he wants to know does mr
barnier believe
the resignation of eu trade commissioner
phil hogan will have a
negative detrimental impact on the
outcome of brexit from an
irish perspective
i don't want to come back on what i said
very sincerely about the philo again
the the friendship and the good very
good very
good cooperation between us all along
the
last four years it is the truth
so i don't want to comment what happens
uh
i'm sure that the new irish commissioner
will
be very proactive uh uh defending uh
the the supporter for you or portfolio
[Music]
but even i am french
i have always been very close from the
irish interest and very attentive to the
irish concerns
i will never forget my meetings in
ireland and northern ireland
with people on the grounds and
the reason why i
pay such an attention to the irish
concerto i will continue
and to be frank
in in that process every member states
at the same influence every member
states
okay um two questions here michelle in
relation to services
um one from um david finnemore
of queen's university belfast he wants
to know
how can the all island economy be
protected in the absence of
the free movement of services and
then um there's a second question here
from john mcgrain who's the dg
of the british irish chamber he wants to
know could mr barnier say
his view on whether services can be
addressed
in adequate time within any deal
at this stage um so just services if you
may
this question is very important because
it is one one sector
services which is a huge important for
the uk and for us
and obviously for for ireland
where you will see a real difference
between a deal and autism
so we are working with the uk
in the global framework of the trade
agreement
on goods and services so
if we succeed to reach a deal there will
be a
important part of the agreement
dedicated to
the services i'm speaking about all the
services except
the financial services which which
which are in a different uh
different process which is a what we
call the equivalences process for
financial services which is not in the
negotiation which is a unilateral
process from the eu side so i think that
if we reach a deal which is my goal our
goal
a large part of the services will be
covered by this agreement
very good um just a question here um
um from um shane uh
cody who's a member of our institute
here and he says or he asks
and he says in the um event of no
agreement which i know we're working to
um
to to to make sure we do get agreement
but he says in the event of no agreement
or a minimal agreement
uh what are the options for further or
new negotiations in early
2021 and are there any procedural
obstacles to further engagement
at that stage
michael is not exactly the same thing to
speak about
no agreement no minimal agreement i know
this uh
wording of the uk speaking about a low
profile agreement
what the uk calls low profile is
nevertheless access
for the uk products the single market is
not really what we
we call a low profile remembering that
we never
propose for any country in the world at
the very beginning of the negotiation
zero tariffs as we did for the uk so it
is
it cannot be a low profile but in any
case uh
even with a low profile agreement in
trade we will need
and we will ask for a credible
framework on the level playing field
if there is no agreement
everybody will see you very soon in four
four four months from now what will
happen and once again it will be a
a huge difference a many chance i
i spoke in my initial remark about what
will happen in
the first on the 1st of january next
year huge change
deal or no deal if there is no deal
in addition to the controls which will
be
an obligation for any goods entering in
single market
we will control this goods to protect
the consumer to protect the budget to
protect the
companies and the businesses but in
addition
of this control we will implement
tariffs
custom tariffs and and kota which will
be a huge
huge difference
if there is another fortunately we will
leave
for our trade relations under the
framework of the double edu
which will be once again a very
important challenge
and many many distortions and many many
uh
problems uh and and uh and frictions
frictions between us unfortunately it
will be
the choice of the uk not our choice uh
and the door of the u will remain open
in any case
okay uh just a question here maybe just
going back on the fisheries issue
if i may again without getting into um
asking you to get into the detail of the
negotiations
if they are underway from kieron
o'driscon from the european movement
here in ireland he wants to know in
terms of fisheries within the brexit
negotiations
what obstacles could be removed that
would allow for an agreement
in this sensitive policy area again i
know you don't want to enter into detail
uh but what steps can be taken um that
would
would help us secure an agreement in
this area
this is a very difficult issue
frankly speaking we are nowhere for the
fishery issue even if we have had
useful clarification and and
discussion but we are still in very
two opposite positions
i've already said that we are ready to
move from our initial position which is
a
no change if the uk move but you can
does that want to move and this is a
problem
the the key problem is that uh
becoming a independent coastal code
obviously the uk will recover the full
sovereignty
on their waters no no no doubt and no
question at this point
but it is another thing another story
speaking about the fish
which are inside the waters and
looking and respecting the international
regulations and
also what is must be done on this
issue we think that we have to speak
about the quota share
to find a sustainable long-term
and balanced agreement with the uk
we are not there so this is the point i
don't want to to enter in the details
but
let me just recall once again
it is my mandate and i
just want to mention that in my days
it's very clear there will be no
trade agreement between the uk and eu
without
a credible framework on level playing
field what i called
the fair play the economic and trade
fair play
and without a sustainable
agreement and balance agreement on
fishery
there will be no trade agreement between
uk
and eu without these two points sold
before
okay so just maybe just one final
question if i may uh
michelle you're heading back uh to
london next week
uh are you going back to london and i
know you've uh you haven't been too
optimistic
uh in your remarks um but are you um
are you expecting um a breakthrough
um then or or when
when do we need to see a breakthrough
and and
what would that break through how would
we know that we've got a breakthrough
when the time comes i mean so time is
running out
you're going back to london i think
there's one more negotiating session
after that so are you hoping
maybe against hope that there will be
some movement on the uk side
that you will see next week
we need the best brexit we need to move
and once again if the uk wants a deal
with us
and a fair agreement
for this zero zero zero zero got access
to the british products to our market of
450 million
consumers they will have to move
and it is their choice it is their
responsibility
we are ready to make fair
and constructive compromise but
not at the detriment of the eu and the
single market and integrity and the
values and the rights
of the consumers the workers the
environmental rights
so i will come back as frequently as
necessary to london
the uk galatians is ready to come back
to brussels
we will work with
respect towards the uk as usual as
always
we will be patient calm i will keep calm
until the day the last day of this
negotiation
and respectful but we will not
change the main lines and we are just
asking
for the uk to understand the key
position of the eu and also if i may
repeat what i said
we just asked for a legal translation
of the political commitment taken by
bori johnson
a few months ago in october in this
document
can take the time to read this document
which is not so long 16 pages
which is a political declaration
ratified
supported approved by the house of
commons
at the same time that the treaty the
wizard agreement
this document is not a speech
it is a political agreement and it is a
commitment
for the two sides given the
framework of the future negotiation so
once again i'm worried and disappointed
but i still think that really possible
you just use the word optimism
you just you just use the word optimism
uh remember michael what what was the
answer of germany
uh one of the grandfather of the eu when
he was asked
mr monet are you optimism or
pessimistic are you optimistic or
pessimistic and his answer was
i'm never optimistic i'm never
pessimistic i'm just
determined yes my feeling today
thank you just there is actually one
just final question here and then we're
going to wrap it up
michelle from uh bruno uh waterfield
from the
at the london times and i think it's a
question that i just want to address to
you and we will finish on this
particular one i think he says i need to
ask
mr barnier about phishing is a contrary
to truth comment uh also on state aid he
says does mr barnier
deny that the uk table room documents
in round seven
i never see new legal documents on
fishing issue
and level playing field in the uk and
the last round
okay that's clear okay well look at on
that basis i think we're going to um
finish um thank you indeed and thank you
to everyone who joined us
this afternoon for such a timely indeed
lively
discussion thank you in particular to
our friends in the european commission
representation office here in dublin
who are our co-hosts for this event but
thank you most of all to you uh michelle
and and we hope at some future date that
you will find it possible
when circumstances permit uh to come
back to ireland to see us in person
uh clearly the coming weeks are going to
be critically important
critically important for ireland uh
critically challenging for the european
union
and the uk and we wish you the very best
in all your endeavors
if i could just say that in two weeks
from today as you mentioned yourself i
think michelle
president dr ursula van der leyn will
deliver her first state of the union
address
and uh following that speech the iiea
will co-host
with our friends in the european
commission representation office and the
european parliament office in dublin
an expert discussion exploring the key
issues arising
in that context and you can get more
details about that
on our website so with that i want to
adjourn
say thank you sincerely uh thank you for
your insight thank you for your candor
uh thank you for just uh for uh for
representing the european union in the
way that you do in these challenging
times
we wish you the very very best and we
just um
would like to say um good thank you very
much
perhaps just if i may just one one
sentence to thank you michael and your
team
i will be always available uh
i hope after uh the the good conclusion
of this negotiation on the deal
which is once again in the common
interest and you mentioned once again
the
very important speech that usually
vanderland
will deliver in two weeks from now this
speech will be about the
current crisis but also on many
ambitions
and project the green deal for instance
of the eu
and the proposal of the commissions and
about the future of europe which is much
more important than the brexit if i may
say
so i remain available and
obviously i will come back to ireland
and nothing island as frequently as
possible in the future thank you very
much
you'll be very welcome indeed so thank
you very much with that we will end
and um and and sign off thank you very
much indeed
you